it's great to be joined today by Blake
Crouch who is an author screenwriter
producer of wayward Pines good behavior
and also author of Dark Matter a novel
that I pretty recently read Blake it's
so great to talk to you I I was
absolutely riveted by dark matter and I
read a lot of different types of books
and one of the things I found really
interesting about it was the sort of
scientific basis that underlies a lot of
it and it really lates it relates to a
lot of pretty hard science that has been
worked on in the science world for quite
some time so I'd love to just first hear
a little bit about how you came up with
the basic concept for the novel and
you're probably better at explaining it
without spoiling anything than I would
so I'll leave that to you and then how
do you think about the science in the
writing that you do hmm well the idea
from dark matter really came from the
science itself I probably 10 or so years
ago
I hate read an article about awesome
physics and I was fascinated by it
because it it really talks about this
whole part of the world that we don't
see and we're not privy to which is
particle physics and strange things that
matter does when we're not looking at it
for instance it sometimes appears to be
in more than one place at a time and it
just had caught my fascination but it's
very dense complex kind of a tough nut
to crack in terms of understanding the
science so I spent the last 10 years or
so when I was writing other things that
we're kind on and good behavior just
doing my due diligence and trying to
understand quantum physics first for
myself say I suppose fascinating but the
more I got into it I started to realize
this could be the premise of a really
interesting novel if done the right way
and I just needed to spend enough time
to understand the science so I could
incorporate it into a book in a way that
wasn't confusing to the reader but was
intriguing and dark matter in some ways
it reads like a time travel book
but there's not actually time travel
taking place rather it's travel sort of
between contemporaneous universes or
instances of the universe did you start
with that as the concept and then work
out the story and characters or did you
start maybe with a character or a plot
idea I started with the idea of the box
itself once I had a grasp on quantum
mechanics I was wondering how would I
write something that allowed a character
to move between worlds and the notion of
the box came to me as I was actually
brainstorming something else and it was
such a strong visual image idea of this
box in a hangar with lights shining down
on it and I mean one of the one of the
interesting things about quantum
mechanics is to make particles exist in
multiple places at the same time we have
to put them in isolation we can't look
at them you have to turn the temperature
down to the absolute zero there can be
no outside interference and once you do
that they're moving across different
realities and and I just wanted to scale
that up so I had idea for this box and
and once I realized that that was my way
into the book the rest of it came pretty
easily do you start knowing the full
story arc and how it's going to go and I
think that with dark matter it's
particularly relevant because of again
without giving anything away about
specific plot points because of the
development of the story it seems to me
as someone who cannot write fiction to
save my life that it would be very
difficult to start writing this without
having a sense of where it's going to go
and ultimately end up well I always have
a sense of where the books are going
when I start I at least know what's
happening up through the midpoints and I
might have an idea or two about the last
act the third act and what happens then
but that almost always changes for dark
matter when I was selling it and I was
explaining to publishers and movie
studios what I thought was going to be
happening in the third act that ended up
changing dramatically
what it is in the book and I'm not gonna
spoil it because I think it's a lot of
fun when the reader encounters that plot
twist but you know it's funny I was
looking back the way I came to that plot
twist as I was looking back through all
of my writing journals and I I spent
several months just taking notes on a
book before I start it and typically
when I get ready to try to finish the
book I'll go back and I'll just look
through my notes and just to see if I
missed anything
were there any kernels of genius in
there that I just forgot to put in the
book and I was really struggling with
third act of dark matter and then I went
back and like on the third day I had
been brainstorming it I had just dashed
off this little note about what happens
to Jason when he gets back to his world
that's what I'm gonna say and it was
exactly the end but I remember writing
it at that point in time thinking oh
that's just too crazy that would never
work and it ended up being exactly what
the book needed but I had to write
though most of the book to realize that
so plot lines aside there's some pretty
pretty dark stuff in in dark matter that
that is experienced by the protagonist
you know I was thinking as I read it
about how we often hear this idea that
comedians are often actually depressed
dark people who are in difficult places
in their life and have suffered through
a lot
I mean we're how does your personal
background connect to some of the
darkness and and difficult stuff that
exists in dark matter or does it yeah
and horror and thriller writers are
actually some of the happiest people
even if they write the darkest stuff and
is it's a inverse thing from comedians I
think um no but in a lot of my books
it's sort of like I think of it as
therapy in Reverse and I don't really
understand what I'm doing at the time
when I'm writing the book in terms of
what am i working out in terms of my own
issues but by the time I get to the end
of the book I have a pretty clear sense
of oh well this is PI I was writing
about that because I'm clearly going
through this thing in my life and it's
not something I try to look too closely
at during the writing of the book
because I think it would be it would
overshadow the
and the characters and all of that stuff
I was trying to pull off but it's
something I've been more and more aware
of over the last several books I want to
talk about some of your other projects
but real quick
are you experiencing that there's some
people confused between your novel and
the TV series by the same name based on
a comic book that's sort of a space
opera the other day I mentioned to
someone I'd be interviewing you they
said oh I recently read the book and I
haven't yet seen the TV series on sci-fi
which of course is another thing
altogether is that is there any
interesting backstory to any of that or
confusion you've seen people have no I
mean I just heard names might think it's
my book spurred the TV show but no I
think if I recall that TV show is in
development when I sold the book I mean
now almost three years ago yeah so you
know they were doing their thing and you
know I was working on this book I mean I
hopefully when the win and if the movie
comes out that won't be any more
confusion okay so let's talk about the
wayward Pines trilogy that was adapted
into a TV series for Fox M night
Shyamalan was the executive producer
when you I'm sorry he also directed the
pilot episode also directed the pilot
episode correct
so when M night Shyamalan you find out
is going to be involved in a project of
turning something you wrote into
something for television is that hugely
exciting or do you also share do you
also have some concerns that it will
become more something in the style of M
night Shyamalan than what you originally
sort of conceived it to be or somewhere
in between I think well I wasn't really
that concerned because I think nights in
my sensibilities are actually very
similar and where I've gotten to know
him that's become apparent our
storytelling instincts happen to line up
in a lot of instances and I think that's
one of the reasons he was attracted to
where it Pines is because it has this
huge twist that no one sees coming and
it was funny when we had first sent the
script with
episode 2 him offering it to him to
consider coming on board to direct the
pilot episode and be an executive
producer he read the script and as you
know the first seat the first episode
ends with Ethan Burke trying to drive
out of Witter Pines not being able to
and it's just this big cliffhanger
moment and night had said as long as
they're not all dead I'm in so I think
he's got this sense of kind of the big
sweeping plot movements hello I still
remember going to see the sixth sense in
when I was in college and walking out of
that theater just blown away by it that
audacious storytelling so I was thrilled
when he came on board I'm even more
excited to when the show turned out to
be as good as it was we were able to
find that audience do there sometimes
have to be sort of candid conversations
where it's sort of communicated to you
listen we understand this is how this
plot element or scene or story component
is in the books but here's why it just
can't be this way when it's on
television are there some components
that are like that yeah often it's it's
me telling the writers and the producers
that because you know there's a instinct
sometimes where there where and I know
it often stories are told that's the
opposite of what I'm going to say but
where people are trying are trying to be
too faithful to the material and not
being willing to take a big departure
where it needs to and I think that's one
of the reasons I've been able to work
well with Hollywood is because I I'm not
Precious about my book once the book is
finished the book is its own thing and
while clearly and every project I write
like there are scenes that absolutely
should be a movie or should be in the TV
show but then there are other scenes
that it really only works in prose and
it wouldn't work visually and I'm aware
of that
in in the production process and often
trying to steer people away from being
too faithful to the source material like
before we let you go are you watching
any TV
shows now what do you watch for fun what
am i watching right now
I just watched flea bag on Amazon a
really funny scathing British comedy but
of course I've been devouring the new
season twin piece
mm-hmm many peaks was a big inspiration
for me growing up I mean it basically I
grew wayward Pines because of Twin Peaks
I thought I would never be a third
season would never happen I just wanted
to write something to make me feel the
way to my Peaks that I think I think
that is one of the coolest most
beautiful things that's ever been made
film or TV so you know that's those are
the two things I'm kind of into at the
moment and I'm just trying to finish my
next book all right we've been speaking
with blake crouch author screenwriter
producer of wayward pines good behavior
he wrote dark matter when can we expect
the next book ah that's a good question
I am hoping sometime maybe late next
year it just depends I need to I'm not
finished with it yet you know might
these books are are taking longer and
longer there's a bit of science and the
new women is it is a very serpentine
complex mind-bending story structure so
I'm really taking my time with it
because science you know I want to I
want to do right by this idea awesome I
look forward to it Blake thanks for
taking time to talk to me today my
pleasure
okay